supergirl stars melissa benoist and  chris would share a seaside smooch the  actors have taken their romance south of  the border to Cancun Mexico and clearly  couldn't keep their hands off each other  you are my kryptonite the 28 year old  brunette beauty and her 28 year old  actor beau rocked black bathing suits  and I witnessed hell's et the pair  didn't seem to care who watched their  passionate PDA face that smile  I'm just happy yeah yeah I like that  dopey grin butterflies in my stomach  happy it's not the first time the duo  has been spotted out together earlier  this month they enjoyed a casual stroll  around Vancouver with their dogs I've  never felt like this about about anyone  in my life it's safe to say we're super  big fans of this super adorable super  girl couple  you